bonjour bienvenue dans parlement hebdo
nous allons faire ensemble le tour de
l'actualité politique et parlementaire
de la semaine avec michaël szames s
bonjour michael jours
françois hollande veut séduire les
investisseurs étrangers il est donc
convié 34 chefs d'entreprises
internationales à l'elysée pour le
premier conseil d'attractivité objectif
restaurer l'image de la france pour les
inciter à investir à la clé quelques
annonces de simplification une page se
tourne dans l'histoire de psa l'état et
le chinois dong fang sont officiellement
entrés au capital de l'entreprise
familiale à parts égales avec la famille
peugeot chacun mais 800 millions d'euros
sur la table les députés ont adopté une
proposition de résolution sur les
réunionnais de la creuse ses enfants de
l'île de la réunion déplacer dans les
années soixante et soixante dix pour
repeupler elle les campagne un épisode
postcoloniale de l'histoire de la france
passée sous silence aujourd'hui reconnu
à l'assemblée nationale bonjour gérard
chartier on va faire ensemble tout le
tour de l'actualité vous connaissez bien
sûr le principe de cette émission vous
êtes député maire de domont c'est dans
le val d'oise est aussi le président des
entretiens de royaumont proche parmi les
proches de françois fillon alors le
portrait est dressé par les députés vos
amis et collègues et puis on en discute
juste après a ajouté jérôme
c'est quelqu'un qui est plutôt compétent
pour les dossiers qui sont les siens qui
est en même temps un élu avec lequel on
a plaisir à mener un débat parce que il
n'est pas dans la facilité l'argument
c'est quelqu'un qui en même temps c'est
toujours dépasserait qu'on sait qu'il
est proche de françois fillon dont il
soutenait beaucoup françois fillon à
bout de bras alors que la politique
budgétaire et économique et fiscale du
gouvernement fillon et de nicolas
sarkozy était extrêmement sinusoïdale
donc c'était pas évident de suivre le
gouvernement est de l'accompagner dans
tous ces revirements successifs en la
matière c'est un un député actif c'est
un garçon qui est toujours qui saute
d'un sujet à l'autre avec beaucoup de
talent sera porte parole très loyal de
françois fillon a d'excellents collègues
je l' ai connu jeunes je les connais
avant qu'il soit député et je trouve que
c'est un bon député un homme politique
d'avenir loyal s'il ya un mot qu'on
devrait retenir c'est celui ci un
qualificatif pour vous qui vous
ressemble oui je crois que ça me
ressemble
c'est même quelque chose dont je suis
assez fier au fond la politique
dans le dans la perception des français
c'est pas forcément la loyauté qui
ressort en premier et moi je pense que
la loyauté aux politiques c'est une
construction personnelle c'est pas
seulement une relation avec quelqu'un
des relations fortes celles que j'ai eu
avec françois fillon en l'occurrence
c'est aussi une affaire de personnes
d'affaires de de façon dont on a envie
de d'être dont on a envie de bâtir
quelque chose de construit enfin bref
d'avancer dans la vie et je trouve que
la loyauté ça fait partie des bonnes
valeurs des valeurs vous êtes proche de
françois fillon évidemment cette
stratégie en ce moment de françois
fillon peut-être un petit peu plus
droitière on l'a vu notamment dans sa
réaction sur le vote en suisse qu'un
quotas d'immigration tout ça c'est
quelque chose que vous vous acceptez de
la part de françois fillon est ce que
vous le prenez aussi pour vous mais en
fait moi j ai toujours que la politique
des quotas j'ai travaillé sur la
question de l'intégration au canada
c'est sûr lire notamment tu l'argument
c'est une politique peut-être plus
droitière qu'on n'avait pas l'habitude
d'entendre chez françois fillon en fait
c'était un non parce que moi je le
connais comme ça c'est à dire qu'il a
une vision extrêmement réaliste de la
vie politique c'est pas quelqu'un qui
est qui est droitier c'est pas quelqu'un
qui se droitise c'est quelqu'un qui a
des valeurs qui les défend qui va
jusqu'au bout de l'allée verte défense
de ces valeurs et parmi ces valeurs
c'est l'intégration plus que tout
françois c'est quelqu'un qui a envie
d'intégrer toutes celles et tous ceux
qui veulent devenir français et pour
nous voyons le vrai françois fillon
exactement et pour les intégrer il faut
simplement veiller à ce que le phénomène
communautaire ou communautariste ne
prennent pas le dessus sur la nation
française et comment on peut y arriver
en veillant à ce que les origines de
toutes les personnes qui souhaitent
rester sur le territoire national soit
suffisamment équilibré de telle sorte
qu'ils aient pas une communauté qui se
forme et qui prennent le pas sur la
nation française le vrai risque au fond
de l'immigration c'est que des personnes
en provenance d'un même territoire
recrée sur le sol français leur
territoire d'origine cei ne faut pas
parce que l'intégration c'est un défi
c'est un défi que doit relever la nation
qui jérôme chartier après je vous en
avais plus avec ça c'est premier sur la
question avec françois fillon mais je
voudrais quand même que vous regardiez
peut-être la une de paris match parce
que vous avez vu ça cette semaine
nicolas sarkozy carla sarkozy ensemble
sur le la route de la reconquête on dit
que normalement nicolas sarkozy françois
fillon pourrait peut-être se reparler
qu'est ce que vous en savez quelque
chose pour moi je pense qu'il se
reparleront lorsque il y aura un sujet
de discussion au fond aujourd'hui quel
est le sujet de discussion est ce que
nicolas sarkozy a décidé de revenir dans
la vie politique ou non en tout cas et
il ne l'a pas exprimé lui directement et
n'en a pas exprimé le désir en tout cas
sûr par entendu donc le moment où
nicolas sarkozy je pense aura pris sa
décision il aura très envie de reprendre
le temps d'un déjeuner avec françois
fillon et en l'occurrence ils auront à
ce moment là est quelque chose
d'important à se dire outre le fait que
je le sais ils partagent
un sentiment d'amitié qui est réel qui
est très anciens comme qu'en ce moment
qu en ce moment dans la vie politique
les circonstances font que nicolas
sarkozy et françois fillon ne se parlent
pas c'est normal c'est normal parce que
s'il y avait un déjeuner organisé le
déjeuner ça serait pour qui ça serait
pour vous les médias ce serait en
quelque sorte la mise en scène d'une
discussion qui voudraient comme il dit
c'est surtout parce que le contenu le
contenu de ce déjeuner n'a pas été
encore arrêtée par nicolas sarkozy
puisque lui même n'a pas dit clairement
s'il voulait où nous revenir dans la vie
politique je pense qu'il ya se passe en
ce moment il y à ce moment très
important qu'il faudra qu'ils qu'ils
accomplissent et comme on dit en
politique le moment venu chartier retour
à donka l'actualité politique de la
semaine lundi françois hollande lancé
une opération séduction vers les chefs
d'entreprise étrangers
le chef de l'état recevait 34 chefs
d'entreprise étrangers à l'elysée pour
un conseil stratégique de l'attractivité
une première opération séduction de
françois hollande à la clé des promesses
et des annonces plutôt bien accueilli
rym ben ameur pour relancer
l'attractivité de la france françois
hollande déroule le tapis rouge aux
grands patrons 34 chefs d'entreprises
internationaux invités à l'elysée 34
entreprises qui pèse lourd 850 milliards
d'euros dans le monde sont 1000 emplois
en france parmi elles samsung nestlé des
sociétés indiennes brésiliennes ou
encore chinoise
françois hollande leur lance un message
clair investissez en france nous n'avons
pas peur des capitaux qui viennent
s'investir en france nous ne voulons pas
nous protéger nous n'avons pas une
conception qui serait étriqué de notre
intérêt national
nous considérons même que la mobilité
des investissements investissements
français à l'étranger investissements
étrangers en france ça fait partie de la
réussite d'un pays et pour attirer les
capitaux le président annonce plusieurs
réformes simplification des démarches
administratives
création d'un passeport talent de quatre
ans pour les chercheurs et délivrance
accélérée des visas pour les
investisseurs
création d'un guichet unique pour les
investissements en france
des annonces globalement bien accueilli
par les chefs d'entreprise ils sont très
intéressés à
comprendre de croix nous on a besoin
pour puisque on puisse continuer à
innover en france c'est france a à des
choses fantastiques
le président et son gouvernement ont
pris il vraiment pris la mesure de ce
qui est à faire pour voir pour redresser
le la capacité productive de ce pays qui
a tous les atouts pour réussir pourtant
pas de grandes annonces sur le sujet le
plus épineux celui des impôts la
pression fiscale française est l'une des
plus élevées d'europe face aux critiques
d'opérations communication le
gouvernement là sur cette journée aura
des suites économiques concrètes
ce conseil de l'attractivité c'était
nécessaire c'est l'occasion de délivrer
un message je pense que c'était utile de
le faire hier le centre d'attractivité
de la france pour les investisseurs
étrangers puis tout le monde le dit
aujourd'hui et cette attractivité en
vérité elle et elle est d'abord
psychologique
ce manque d'attractivité pourquoi parce
que le message de la taxation à 75% a
été simplement dévastateur dévastateur
il faut savoir que pendant pratiquement
six mois les étrangers ne parlait que de
ça aux français lorsqu'ils les
rencontrais c'était pratiquement un
sentiment de spoliation de la part des
étrangers alors bien sûr françois
hollande est revenu en marche arrière
toute sur ce sujet mais le mal était
fait ce qui fait que cette initiative
aulas est nécessaire parce qu'il va
falloir que monsieur hollande
reconstruisent ceux qui la détruit
pendant plusieurs mois à force de parler
de la finance irresponsable à force de
parler des entrepreneurs qui veulent
s'en mettre plein les poches maintenant
il faut revenir à l'esprit la plus juste
trouvez pas que la france est attractive
je pense qu'elle l'a aujourd'hui un vrai
problème de perception de son
attractivité oui de la faute du
gouvernement est la faute de françois
hollande facile
enfin phénomène de france machine qu'on
entend on régulièrement l'occurrence
personne n'y participe puisque on a
voulu au contraire pendant des années en
l'occurrence avec l'ancienne majorité
construire une vraie attractivité des
entreprises étrangères sur le territoire
français ça marchait plutôt bien mais
les entreprises étrangères sont très
sensibles à ce que les politiques disent
en france parce qu'ils savent très bien
qu en france les politiques ont
énormément de responsabilités aussi bien
sûr énormément de pouvoir
ça signifie que lorsqu'un politique
envoie un message il faut qu'il soit
très prudent par rapport à sa perception
de l'étranger en l'occurrence françois
hollande n'a pas été prudents il a
envoyé des messages qui ont été
destructeurs pour l'attractivité
française donc maintenant il a fait
marche arrière maintenant il essaye de
s'y prendre autrement mais le chemin est
assez long pour pouvoir renouer avec une
vraie attractivité sur le territoire
national la question que soulève aussi
les chefs d'entreprise étrangers c'est
la fiscalité trop compliqué des
allers-retours en permanence oui je
voudrais dire un point enfin un mot sur
cette question alors que l'attractivité
que là que la fille ce qu'elle est
aujourd'hui soit trop lourde la réponse
est oui elle est vraiment trop lourde
que les charges qui pèsent sur l'emploi
en france soient trop élevé oui elles
sont trop élevés il faut faire quelque
chose en revanche sur la complexité de
la fiscalité il faut pas croire que les
entreprises étrangères ne sont pas
parfaitement adapté aux subtilités de la
fiscalité française ils le sont ils la
connaissent ils ont l'habitude de la
pratique et d'ailleurs ils pratiquent
très bien ce qu'on a maintenant la sq
l'on appelle l'optimisation fiscale
c'est-à-dire l'utilisation des lois
existantes alors bien sûr j'entends la
majorité aujourd'hui et qui dit qu' il y
à de l'abus mais il n'y a pas d'abus en
réalité il y à l'utilisation des lois
qui existent et au fond c'est le rôle du
gouvernement de faire en sorte de
modifier ses lois pour faire que la
fiscalité soit la plus juste possible
est-ce que vous observe c'est que le
gouvernement ne fait rien qui ne bouge
pas le corpus fiscal français il devrait
le faire il ne le fait pas il ne le fait
pas parce qu'ils ne veut pas travailler
sur l'essentiel c'est à dire sur les
lois fiscales ça c'est du travail c'est
beaucoup moins drôle que de faire de la
communication mais ça serait beaucoup
plus efficace pour faire en sorte que
les recettes rentrer dans les caisses de
l'état on va passer au mardi on va
continuer un petit peu sur ce cas mais
là avec les entreprises et les patrons
pierre gattaz fait encore parler de lui
ses propos étaient très surveillés après
sa sortie la semaine dernière aux états
unis à propos du pacte de compétitivité
il a donné une conférence de presse
cette semaine avec des propos qui ont à
nouveau fait réagir au nez coups de
pierre gattaz il faut impérativement
qu'il se passe quelque chose et qu'il y
est
idéalement une suspension un moratoire
de ces projets de loi et propositions de
lois qui sont en tuyaux qui vont être
autant de contraintes autant
d'obligations autant de stress sur le
dos débattront vous le reprenez à votre
compte ça l'idée du moratoire on arrête
tout sur les lois qui stresse les
patrons sur notre pierre gattaz mais
surtout j'ai entendu parler du phoque de
simplification il ya quelques mois par
françois hollande françois hollande et
les dirigeants qui vient dé gérer moi
spécialiste des mobiles limite c'est en
lien direct avec ce que vient de dire
pierre gattaz pierre gattaz dit la même
chose que monsieur hollande sauf que
l'obligation sauf que lui serait il le
dit parce que c'est pas fait et françois
hollande le disait il ya quelques mois
quand même 20 pendant quelques mois
qu'est ce qui s'est passé en revanche
aussi on a supprimé une cinquantaine de
commissions et franchement tout le monde
s'en fiche l'important c'est de
supprimer des textes de lois qui sont
inutiles en l'occurrence qui font peser
de la responsabilité sur l'entreprise
est d'accord avec l'idée du moratoire
faut le faire il faut le faire vite je
vous donne un exemple ya une loi qui la
loire qui est en discussion là autour
des travailleurs détachés l'occurrence
des travailleurs étrangers qui
travaillent sur le territoire national
qu'est ce que j'observe dans cette loi
qui barre d'un pont d'un bon sentiment
d'ailleurs c'est un bon sentiment
puisque nous sommes à l'origine de la
proposition de résolution qui conduit à
cette loi et qu'on avait fait voter au
mois de juin 2013 qu'est ce que dit
cette loi elle dit il faut que les
travailleurs détachés en france
travaillent dans des conditions sociales
équivalentes de celle des travailleurs
français soit bon on n'a pas encore
touché de la différence du coût du
travail entre un travailleur d'étagés t
d'acier étranger qui vient travailler en
france et un travailleur français qui
travaillent en france là ça continue à
être plus chers en france que lorsque le
travailleur et détachés de l'étranger
mais bon soit on a commencé à faire une
petite d'avancé sauf que sur qui repose
l'essentiel des contraintes de cette loi
sur les chefs d'entreprise ça veut dire
qu'en vérité le chef d'entreprise au
travers de cette fois il a récupéré une
dizaine de contraintes supplémentaires
voilà le bilan d'une loi qui en même
temps fait incontestablement avancer le
progrès social c'est une loi
contraignante pour les entrepreneurs moi
je voudrais terminer ses combinés arrête
de faire des lois ou l'essentiel des
contraintes repose sur les entrepreneurs
il faut que le gouvernement l'état
prenne sa part de responsabilité et
assume lorsqu'il veut davantage réguler
ou davantage surveillés de faire lui
même le travail et de ne pas le confier
aux entrepreneurs qui ont franchement
autre chose à faire alors mardi à
l'assemblée a adopté une résolution
mémorielle sur les réunionnais de la
creuse dans les années 60 et 70 l'état
organisé des convois d'enfants de l'île
vers des zones rurales de métropole pour
repeupler les campagnes un traumatisme
pour ses enfants déplacés dont certains
étaient présents dans l'hémicycle
valérie brochard
pour mon essence du russe une enfant
volée et moment qu'on a trompé
marie thérèse gasp a découvert sa
véritable identité il y a dix ans
seulement adopté par un couple de la
creuse ce n'est qu'après des années de
recherches qu'elle a compris son
histoire vraiment laisse l'enfant
en disant on va les récupère va
reprendre mon enfant compte ce serait
rétabli un an plus tard
elle demande sa fille
et en la mairie le dire votre fille
sarah yen avait clamé parce qu'elle est
partie en france entre 1963 et 1982 sous
l'impulsion de michel debré alors député
de la réunion
1615 enfants réunionnais abandonnés sont
envoyés vers l'hexagone pour repeupler
les régions rurales désertées mais
difficile d'en trouver la trace dans les
dossiers d'adoption dans mon dos et ils
ont des signatures est personnellement
pour me l'expliquer cet après midi marie
thérèse a rejoint devant l'assemblée une
trentaine de réunionnais exilés
c'est dire la plus grande de
la députée socialiste de la réunion
présente une résolution mémorielle qui
considère que l'état a manqué à sa
responsabilité morale la république
connu un triple échec dans cette affaire
morales d'abord avec des enfants brisés
passer par pertes et profits écrasé par
un choix politique est une machine
administrative qui refusèrent toute
remise en cause pour marie thérèse comme
pour les plus de 1600 exilés c'est la
reconnaissance de l'histoire du passé
mais surtout la possibilité de mieux
diffuser cet épisode méconnu hors de la
réunion et peut-être libéré la parole
d'autres puppy de l'état qui ne se sont
pas encore fait connaître
l'ump s'est abstenue sur ce vote sur
cette résolution mémorielle pour quelle
raison parce qu'on n'avait pas voté
contre en l'occurrence c'est un sujet
que moi j'ai découvert en franchise j'en
ignorais l'existence j'ignorais
l'existence de de ces personnes qui ont
été placées c'est effectivement afin de
malheureux qui s'est produit très
important soit et donc une
reconnaissance qui me semble tout à fait
normal de demander
réparation à la justice par exemple
c'est toujours là une question très très
sensible et très compliqué de demander
réparation pour jeudi raid et des
responsabilités des faits qui ont été
commis par d'autres et au fond c'est
certes une une responsabilité publique
puisque en l'occurrence c'est un
responsable public qui a pris cette
décision lors je pense qu'on aurait dû
sans doute mieux la pesée à l'époque est
d'ailleurs ce qui est très intéressant
c'est de voir s'il aurait pu se
reproduire aujourd'hui nous on n'aurait
pas eu ses propres durs aujourd'hui
puisque la la décision politique à mon
avis davantage réguler avec notamment
toutes celles et tous ceux qui
aujourd'hui prennent la parole dans le
débat public je pense que c'est une
bonne chose après sur les questions de
réparation ça reste toujours en vol et
d'une complexité extrême chacun peut
observer sur d'autres affaires on a le
sentiment quand même que c'est difficile
aujourd'hui en france évoquée se passe
et postcoloniale non c'est pas difficile
je crois qu'il faut le regarder avec
beaucoup de lucidité
je voudrais qu'on essaye d'avoir une une
vision juste sur ce qu'a été la la
logique coloniale de la france c'est une
logique qui a permis aussi le
développement il faut le reconnaître
mais d'un autre côté ça permis ça ça
produit plutôt des des excès importants
sur lesquels il convient de revenir donc
ça me semble juste pour moi l'oubli
c'est terrible oubliez ce que l'on a été
oublié nos erreurs c'est terrible en
même temps oublier nos fantastiques
succès ça serait dommage on va changer
de sujet je vous parlais la semaine
dernière des ogm et de ce projet de loi
qui est examiné en urgence au sénat et
bien surprise le sénat l'a rejetée ce
qui a agacé passablement le gouvernement
les explications de mounir souci une
course contre la montre s'engage pour
bloquer le maïs ogm en france le
ministre de l'écologie va soutenir une
nouvelle proposition de loi dans ce sens
le revirement du sénat un incident
parlementaire aux yeux de philippe
martin qui n'entame pas la détermination
du gouvernement une position purement
idéologique pour le principal syndicat
agricole
je veux qu'on sorte définitivement du
débat pour ou contre c'est plus le débat
aujourd'hui le débat c'est qu'est ce que
peuvent amener
demain des technologies de type ogm à la
fois d'ailleurs pour les plantes comme
pour les animaux mais quels sont les
risques et quels sont les inconvénients
les partisans de la culture du maïs
transgénique produit notamment par la
société américaine monsanto souhaite
dépolitiser le débat pour l'emmener sur
le terrain scientifique
les agences ont toujours considéré et
ceci depuis 2011 que le maïs monsanto
810 n'était pas plus je dirais
désagréable pour l'environnement que le
maïs conventionnel des arguments rejetés
par les écologistes qui mettent en avant
les dangers de ces cultures pour la
biodiversité cet épisode a au moins une
vertu ils ressoudent les verts le parti
socialiste souvent en désaccord depuis
le début du quinquennat pour revenir à
la décision d'hier soir et à la volonté
du gouvernement de bien tenir nous
évidemment en tant qu écolo on est sur
cette ligne là et là pour le coup on est
fier d'être 7 de cette majorité est de
soutenir le gouvernement la paire
devrait se régler au niveau européen où
la france est en désaccord avec la
commission qui elle plaide pour
l'autorisation de la culture ogm sur le
continent jérôme chartier c'est une
victoire des pro ogm ou des fêtes du
gouvernement sur ce texte là non ça
montre surtout que c'est un sujet qu'on
n'a pas traité sur le plan politique en
a eu tort
arrivé à interdire même la recherche
c'est s'agissant des ogm c'est une
erreur magistrale c'est un vrai recul du
progrès elle de même que lorsque l'on
interdit aujourd'hui la recherche
s'agissant de l'extraction de du gaz de
schiste c'est une erreur colossale il
faut qu'on autorise la recherche en
france il faut qu'on arrive à
dépassionner le débat j'aimerais bien
qu'on puisse avoir un débat national sur
la question des ogm ont lâché mais
jamais je me regarde en disant ça
puisque notre majorité non plus d'accord
là où je me réjouis c'est qu'en fait à
l'occasion de ce nom vote de cette loi
le débat on recommence à surgir
s'agissant de la question des ogm il
faut qu'on arrive une fois pour toutes à
l'engager il faut engager il faut aimer
nationale où il faut il faut qu'on
conduisent il faut surtout à l'issue de
ce débat qu'on décide ou moins je pense
d'autoriser la recherche c'est une
erreur colossale d'interdire la
recherche s'agissant des ogm le projet
de loi sera examinée en avril à
l'assemblée qu'est-ce que vous voterez
vous attendez d'avoir le débat ensemble
des besoins j'ai besoin d'avoir ce débat
la question des ogm c'est une question
qui est qui qui pour moi earth deux
phénomènes d'une part c'est toujours
l'inquiétude s'agissant de l'aliment est
ce qu'on modifie l'aliment et donc par
conséquent est ce qu'on fait prendre des
risques aux consommateurs phénomène
numéro un phénomène numéro 2 est ce
qu'on peut améliorer la performance de
production qui pourrait rendre service à
nombre d'habitants quand je dis nombre
c'est plusieurs centaines de millions
d'habitants sur la surface de la planète
qui ont besoin de sourire et qui ne
peuvent se nourrir dans de bonnes
conditions du fait des aliments
classiques et donc les aliments ils ont
besoin d'être adapté les cultures en
l'occurrence à des territoires à des
environnements donc millions de sécurité
environnementale c'est la raison pour
laquelle il y a déclinant solutions de
sécurité environnementale mais des
questions de sécurité alimentaire et
c'est pour ça qu'on a besoin d'un débat
parce qu'on a besoin d'être éclairé sur
l'ensemble de ces sujets moi je suis
prêt à être éclairé et je suis prêt
après envoûté à voter comment dire en
conscience de cause la seule chose c'est
une chose doit bien comprendre et bien
appréhender sujet ce que j'observe c'est
nombre de collectes comme moi
n'appréhende pas suffisamment ce sujet
parce qu'au fond on le ressent c'est
presque un tabou c'est un tabou chez les
écologistes qui disent jamais les ogm et
puis il ya les les volontaires du
progrès qui disent il faut surtout les
ogm moi j'aimerais bien pouvoir me faire
mon opinion sans tabou qu'on puisse
conduire une vraie discussion qu'elle
soit utile et si on pouvait la conduire
en même temps que celle sur le gaz de
schiste ça serait vraiment fantastique
l'actualité politique c'est aussi la
campagne des élections municipales la
grande inconnue c'est l'abstention c'est
notre zoom de la semaine
thomas guénolé bonjour vous êtes
politologue maître de conférences à
sciences po la tension donc c'est la
grande inconnue mais c'est aussi la
grande inquiétude de ses prochaines
élections alors cette semaine le
gouvernement a dévoilé un site internet
et des clips pour mobiliser les
électeurs et leur expliquer le vote
regardez moi je suis super attentive à
ma ville alors quand il ya du neuf pour
l'élection du maire j'ouvre les rieurs
maintenant dans les communes des mille
habitants et plus un seul et même
bulletin de vote présentera deux listes
de candidats une pour les candidats à
l'élection municipale et une pour
l'élection des conseillers
communautaires vous savez les élus qui
gèrent la coopération intercommunale
comme le ramassage scolaire ou le
traitement des eaux je ne sais pas vous
mais moi je trouve ça vraiment important
du coup ça me donne encore plus envie
d'aller voter 23 mars 30 mars élections
municipales oui je vote
alors thomas guénolé quelles sont les
prévisions d'abstention pour ses futures
municipales
d'abord je ne sais plus qui disait que
la prédiction est un art difficile en
particulier en ce qui concerne l'avenir
mais
historiquement ça tourne entre 60 et 70
% ce qui est faible pour des élections
en dehors des élections générales qui
maintenant sont quinquennal mais si on
se retrouve avec une abstention de
l'ordre de 70% ce sera significativement
plus élevé que d'habitude
alors il ya des abstentions qui viennent
simplement du fait que le le maire
sortant est indéboulonnable depuis des
siècles et donc les gens ne prennent pas
la peine d'aller voter parce que de
toute façon il guérit les gi l'été il
est élu d'avancé sauf que parfois ça
peut entraîner par abstention de son
camp lui le fait que ce soit le camp
d'en face qui gagne c'est la surprise
c'est une parenthèse mais ça arrive hein
c'est pas une blague on se sait plus
dans des petites communes langue ce
genre de choses peut se produire après
vous avez une abstention et c'est
beaucoup plus répandue qui est une forme
de vote anti système c'est à dire que
pour rejeter le système politique vous
avez des gens qui viennent voter blanc
par esprit de civisme tout en refusant
de choisir qui que ce soit dans l'offre
politique disponibles et puis vous avez
des gens qui
plutôt que de voter front national front
de gauche ou que sais-je
décide de rester chez eux c'est le
fameux partie des pêcheurs à la ligne
qui est le premier parti de france mais
de très loin alors on dit souvent ce
sont plus ceux ci se sont plus cela en
fait l'abstention est répartie de
manière assez équitable dans toute la
population à une exception près les gens
qui votent exprès extrêmes se mobilise
plus que la moyenne pour toutes les
élections puisqu'ils sont dans une mais
c'est qu'une forme d'abstention quelque
part vous créiez aussi cette abstention
oui alors je crois que c'est gauche
comme à droite
guénolé c'est eux c'est pas une
abstention de 70 % c'est une
participation de 70% et une abstention
de l'ordre de 30% qui est effectivement
une abstention assez classique que l'on
retrouve sur sur ce genre de d'élection
je souscris bien sûr parce qu'il vient
d'être dit sévissant des différentes
catégories d'abstentionnistes au fond la
loi sur le vote blanc qui est en train
d'être votée va peut-être permettre non
elle va peut-être permettre de réduire
le phénomène d'abstention moi j'avais
écrit un livre dans les années 2005 2006
qui s'appelait lui fit le lifting de
marianne à travers ce livre je faisais
50 propositions pour rénover la vie
politique française est l'une des
propositions c'était la reconnaissance
du vote blanc parce que je pense que
cette reconnaissance permet
effectivement de réduire l'abstention
si c'est simplement de reconnaître le
vote blanc c'est à dire pour les gens
qui nous regardent le comptabiliser on
verra et il ya tant de votes blancs
alors qu'actuellement c'est votre bon
vieux temps sioniste bulletins nuls etc
alors c'est voilà ces abstentionnistes
de la côte et puis ensuite votes blancs
et nuls peu et j'entends bien donc on
fusionne event blancs et nuls moi je
pense que le fait d'identifier le vote
blanc si vous voulez sac signifie que le
comportement politique du vote blanc est
un comportement qui est identifié mais
voilà merci s'il n'a pas de conséquence
sur le sort de l'élection il ya un
problème c'est à dire que je crois que
c'est en serbie de mémoire ou leur
système politique veut que si on
n'atteint pas un certain quota de
participation électorale lors il sait
faible je crois que c'est 50 % mais moi
l'élection est invalidée il faut la
refaire oui si vous faites ça du jour au
lendemain le fait d'être ou le
pourcentage de votes blanc va être
comptabilisé s'il atteint certains
seuils l'élection est invalidée en fait
il là ce savoir
alors qu'en france en france existe
c'est existe simplement alors plus
exactement c'est pas une invalidation
d'élections mais c'est simplement le
fait qu'au premier tour pour celles et
ceux qui pour être élu au premier tour
si on n'atteint pas au minimum je le
phénomène de 25% des inscrits qui
s'exprime donc là nous avons
effectivement une impossibilité d'être
élu ce qui sans validation du candidat
la validation et le petit là il a enlevé
et là et là en l'occurrence si vous
voulez ça c'est quand même une mécanique
assez importante puisque ça permet
d'identifier entre guillemets le
mécontentement donc moi je pense que les
médias comme toujours vont jouer leur
rôle et qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire
lorsqu'il y aura vote blanc fort qui
s'exprimera à l'occasion de certains
scrutins ils ne manqueront pas de le
signaler de le mettre en relief et en
l'occurrence immolé ça sera identifié
cette fois comme un refus c'est la
raison pour laquelle je trouve que c'est
une vraie avancée parce que jusqu'à
présent c'est les abstentionnistes
autrement dit c'est les pêcheurs à la
ligne les mécontents bref si tout le
monde là au moins ceux qui se déplacent
pour aller voter blanc c'est la décision
d'avoir un comportement politique pour
marquer une forme de mécontentement de
matinée les vous décrivez ce livre mon
songe en politique petit guide du
mensonge en politique juste pour ça sort
début mars et ça sort le 6 mars m de
quoi il est question elle dont elle en
fait c'est un livre dans lequel on lit
le grand mot comme bella sur wii c'est à
dire que en fait j'ai constaté que c'est
un thème absolument central pour les
électeurs ne pas vouloir se faire
arnaquer au même titre que la publicité
dans la consommation pour faire leurs
courses et donc ce dont il s'agissait
d'aborder dans chaque chapitre une façon
utilisée par la classe politique pour
nous mentir et à la fin pour vous
entraîner à les repérer vous avez des
exercices avec leurs corrigés tous
s'engagent
thomas guénolé donc petit guide du
bourgeon politique merci de nous avoir
éclairé notamment sur l'abstention va
passer un tout autre sujet cette fois
pas ce mercredi avec l'avenir de psa
l'officialisation a eu lieu mercredi le
chinois dong feng et l'état sont entrés
au capital de psa la famille peugeot et
les deux nouveaux actionnaires
détiendront chacun 1 14% de la marque au
lion de quoi assurer l'avenir du groupe
qui a enregistré une perte nette de 2
milliards 300 millions d'euros en 2013
françois goulard
une page se tourne pour psa après des
mois de négociations le chinois dongfeng
deuxième constructeur mondial
d'automobiles fait son entrée au capital
de peugeot à hauteur de 800 millions
d'euros et l'état français investit lui
aussi la même somme 800 millions d'euros
pour la première fois la famille peugeot
n'est donc plus majoritaires chacun des
trois partenaires possédera 14% du
capital aujourd'hui clip varin a annoncé
les résultats annuels du groupe chiffre
d'affaires en baisse de 2,4 pour cent
désormais la marque au lion se tourner
vers l'avenir redressement en europe
compte est à internationale avec
dongfeng et puis troisième point les
moyens de nos ambitions puisque avec une
augmentation de capital qui s'élèvera à
3 milliards d'euros nous allons pouvoir
investir plus en recherche développement
nous allons pouvoir investir plus dans
nos usines alors en france nous avons
pris des engagements mais aussi à
l'international ses entrées d'argent
sont une bouffée d'oxygène pour psa qui
sort de deux ans de grosses difficultés
financières
marqué par des fermetures d'usinés comme
celle d'aulnay et des suppressions de
postes alors l'entrée au capital de
l'état est saluée à droite comme à
gauche l'alliance avec dongfeng et avec
l'état français donne une nouvelle
dimension où elle amène à la fois des
marchés nouveaux et aussi des capitaux
de long terme notamment grâce à l'état
français qui permettent et qui
permettront d'éviter les plans sociaux
l'état à raison de rentrer au capital et
nous faut une politique industrielle
c'est le seul moyen contenu d'absence
politique industrielle au niveau
européen pour pouvoir contrôler les
choses lorsque vous fait rentrer les
chinois dans la bergerie il faut leur
mettre une muselière l'accord final sera
signé fin mars à l'occasion de la visite
du président chinois xi jinping
peut-être la fin de deux années noires
pour psa alors jérôme chartier
fallait-il entrée laisser entrer ps ah
pardon le chinois dongfeng et l'état au
capital de psa je voudrais dire en fait
que le coc aujourd'hui le capitalisme
familial n'est plus d'échelle mondiale
hal quelques rares exceptions près ça
signifie que si on a envie de
s'intéresser au monde il faut qu'on a
sali est-ce que c'est pas un petit peu
le loup dans la bergerie comme le disait
jacques myard oui toutes façons à sa
façon lorsque vous prenez la décision de
vous et lit d'abord avec l'état en fait
la famille peugeot est que cette
alliance fait que vous avez ce que l'on
appelle la minorité de blocage dans le
tour de table ça veut dire que avec
l'état la famille peugeot bloc toutes
les décisions qui seraient contraires la
stratégie du groupe vous avez un verrou
qui est très fort qui est très solide et
dans ce cas là vous pouvez vous alliez
avec des partenaires en l'occurrence
l'entreprise en scène en chine qui fait
que vous avez accès à un marché qui
représentent aujourd'hui le quart des
ventes automobiles mondiales c'est le
marché chinois c'est donc ce marché très
important pour un constructeur
automobile en l'occurrence approuvé
concepteurs qui ont des transferts de
technologie se pose aussi notamment avec
la question des transferts de
technologie se posera mais se posera dès
lors qu'il y aura une volonté qui sera
celle du groupe psa d'aller plus loin
dans pour l'instant l'entrée au capital
du groupe de la part de dong feng on
peut par exemple imaginer
trapel une joint-venture c'est à dire
une alliance réel entre psa et dongfeng
en chine s'agissant de la construction
des modèles donc c'est un début c'est un
début d' aventure mais ce que je veux
dire c'est qu'on a aujourd'hui la chance
pour un pays comme la france 60 millions
d'habitants d'avoir encore deux
constructeurs automobiles de dimension
mondiale il y avait un vrai besoin pour
le groupe psa de s'internationaliser
donc les gardiens fait je pense que
c'est nécessaire et le rôle de l'état le
retour de l'état
là pour le coup est essentiel l'état
c'est cet actionnaire doit être un état
stratège un état stratège qui solidifie
le l'actionnariat des entreprises de
telle sorte de contrôler avec la
minorité de blocage le fait qu'à
l'avenir ces groupes ne quitte pas la
france c'est bien de stratégie
économique et industriel dont on parle
et là sont nés en l'occurrence une
illustration très bonne voilà une bonne
action du gouvernement oh oui mais ils
savaient ils n'en ont fait qu'à suivre
le chemin qu'on avait déjà initié depuis
plusieurs années enfin au coeur de la
crise financière françois fillon nicolas
sarkozy font quoi ils soutiennent mon
accident soutiennent oui je le dis c'est
non seulement je dis que c'était très
bien mais je dis aussi la vérité c'est
que c'est dans le droit fil de ce que
nous nous avions fait il faut dans ce
cas là il faut toujours tout reconnaître
c'est à dire la vérité qui arrange et
celle du bérange et en l'occurrence
j'observe que la majorité actuelle a
plus l'habitude de reconnaître la vérité
qui dérange et moins facilement celles
qui le dérange on va parler du vin si
vous le voulez bien avec le vin qui est
inscrit au patrimoine national il était
temps
en vous le savez très bien quand on
parle de la france on parle de ce pays
notamment de la gastronomie du bon vin
et bien le sénat a adopté un amendement
en commission qui reconnaît le vin comme
faisant partie du patrimoine culturel
gastronomique et paysager de la france
toutes les explications horreya mousli
qu'il soit rouge blanc ou même rose et
le vin et la boisson alcoolisée préférée
des français le sénat vient d'adopter en
commission un amendement qui élève le
vin au rang de patrimoine culturel une
excellente nouvelle pour ce propriétaire
d'un bar à vin parisien c'est bien parce
que comme ça on fera pas l'allemagne
gamme entre justement des gens qui font
du vin et qui sont des passionnés de
leurs produits de leur métier de leur
terroir qui met en avant un savoir faire
et un terroir et l'amalgamme avec
l'alcoolisme quoi donc je trouve que
c'est une très bonne chose il serait
tant en france qu'en fin
on reconnaît ce que c'est un métier
d'artisan et ce sont des artistes
derrière les bouteilles sur les 22
régions que compte l'hexagone 17
produisent du vin ce qui fait de la
france le deuxième producteur de vin au
monde juste derrière l'italie une fierté
française qu entendent bien défendre les
sénateurs on a déjà te poser un texte de
loi visant à séparer le vin des alcools
sais que c'est difficile à faire il
reste que le vin est un facteur de
culture est un vecteur de culture est un
vecteur aussi de bien vivre d'altérité
ça n'est pas toujours
parfait entre guillemets la drogue qu'on
voudrait présenter de façon honteuse
chaque français boit en moyenne 53
litres de vin par an la france est donc
le deuxième plus gros consommateur de
vin au monde une consommation que ce
spécialiste juge encore trop excessive
il ne comprend pas la démarche des
sénateurs s'il voulait peut-être
avancées en terme de santé publique et
en même temps ne pas détruire après tout
une activité qui a effectivement une
histoire il faudrait s'y prendre
autrement que ce coup là qui est
hypocrite mal joué si la consommation
des français a diminué de moitié en 50
ans l'excès d'alcool reste responsable
de 50 mille décès par an
leuven alcool comme un autre où partent
à consommer avec modération
c'est un mais c'est le vin c'est un
alcool bien sûr mais c'est une histoire
aussi c'est d'une culture c'est vrai
tout ce qui a été dit sur le vin par par
un certain nombre de collègues que j'ai
observé
et juste bon je pense qu'il faut noter
une chose très importante ce qui me
semble très bonne d'ailleurs c'est que
la consommation de vin en france a
diminué et puis le pendant et c'est vrai
aussi c'est qu'on est à lier davantage
vers de la qualité c'est à dire que les
produits d'origine me nicole ont
augmenté en qualité on a davantage
construit des appellations c'est-à-dire
en l'occurence des terroirs des petits
vins de pays et tout cela ça fait
progresser la culture je trouve les
cultures française et la culture des
terrils à deux un sentiment de
protection là qu'on encadre un petit peu
le vin comme patrimoine national s'il ya
qu'on a peur notamment des investisseurs
étrangers ou de perdre cette
appréciation
plus exacte et le vin français tellement
populaire qu'il est largement copiée à
travers le monde ont fait des fausses
étiquettes de vins français et on met à
l'intérieur rien de plus que de la
bibine des choses horribles horrible
d'avoir et après on dit que c'est du vin
français donc ça c'est pas acceptable
donc il faut protéger ce patrimoine
le vin c'est aussi une histoire d'amour
c'est une histoire d'amour entre un
producteur entre un propriétaire terrien
et puis ce qu'ils arrivent à produire à
l'issue donc il faut protéger tout cela
il faut bien sûr que la france continue
exactement continuer aller vers la
qualité est toujours continué à
consommer avec modération
la prochaine étape c'est l'inscription
au patrimoine culturel de l'humanité
quelle bonne idée je suis leur fait
moins d'accord donc j'insiste sur le
côté de consommation avec modération
parce qu'on peut parfaitement déguster
un vin en en consommant peu cette
semaine le plus de l'hebdo vous invite
au cinéma
retour sur cette semaine sur toute une
série de films consacrée à l' esclavage
amistad lincoln django ou encore toiles
vias live de steve mcqueen qui recevait
le prix du meilleur film et meilleur
acteur lors de la cérémonie des bafta un
thème qui s'impose dans le cinéma mais
que la france encore du mal à aborder
simon barbarie
c'était le week-end dernier le film
twelve year relève de steve mcqueen
recevait le prix du meilleur film et
meilleur acteur lors de la cérémonie des
bafta l'équivalent britannique des
oscars américains le film retrace
l'histoire vraie de salomon nord top
musiciens noirs de l'état de new york
qu'il n'a p en 1841 pour être vendue
comme esclave et le serviteur n'obéit
pas à son seigneur celui là sera battu
par le fouet de nombreuses fois parole
devant la condition de vos travailleurs
elle est abject sa propriété vous
l'annoncer avec fierté j'ai donc ça fait
mal doit disposer de sa reprise avec
amistad et lincoln de steven spielberg
ou plus récemment django de quentin
tarantino l'esclavagé est un thème
récurrent des grosses productions
américaines et le cinéma français dans
tout ça pour le président du cran louis
georges tin les producteurs peine à
s'intéresser à l'histoire des minorités
seule grosse production sur le sujet
case départ de thomas ngijol et fabrice
éboué diffusé cette semaine sur la tnt
malgré ces deux millions de spectateurs
en salles le film a suscité la polémique
par son traitement comique
c'est où toi je rapporte en
tout ça parce que je suis noir et puis
s'il a fallu attendre la loi taubira
2001 pour que la traite négrière soit
reconnu comme crime contre l'humanité et
2006 pour que le 10 mai sous instaurée
comme journée commémorative de
l'abolition de l'esclavagé
force est de constater que le sujet
reste sensible en france en tout cas sur
grand écran on l'a vu notamment avec les
enfants réunionnais pourquoi est ce que
c'est un sens un sujet aussi sensible en
france l'esclavagé c'est difficile
d'assumer des défauts de pareilles en
revanche on n'est pas dans la même
situation entre la france et les
etats-unis et pour les etats-unis il
faut se rappeler quand même que là c'est
à la ségrégation était encore existantes
au 20e siècle ça signifie que les états
unis ont démarré l'abolition de
l'esclavagé et de toute forme de
discrimination extrêmement tardivement
contrairement à la france en france bien
sûr lorsqu'on regarde à passer que je
qualifie de passé douloureux on a
toujours des difficultés à l'assumer je
crois qu'en même temps une nation en 2d
dit lorsqu'elle est capable de l'assumer
le cinéma c'est une façon de faire ce
devoir de mémoire oui c'est une façon de
rappeler ce qui a été fait ce qui a été
commis l'histoire de
ce film de deux heures pardon
c'est juste une histoire
dramatique qui rappellent si vous voulez
que dans un même pays il y avait deux
façons de considérer une personne de
couleur noire de façon entre le nord et
le sud une personne qui était saluée
c'est le thème du film pour son talent
au violon et la même personne qui
quelques centaines de kilomètres plus au
sud a été traité comme un esclave privé
de toute forme de droit aussi c'est
aussi aux politiques de se saisir de ce
thème parce que dieudonné par exemple
s'est saisi de l' esclavage pour faire
un petit peu son commerce aussi 71 c'est
très dangereux ça laisse des espaces je
suis d'accord mais au fond
c'est l'occasion de se rappeler de
du comportement du politique le
politique est capable de prendre de très
bonnes décisions il est capable aussi
d'en prendre de très mauvaise et tout
cela au sein d'un même pays ça signifie
que
chaque chaque nation doit progresser
dans la prise en considération de
l'autre et en même temps elle peut le
faire et voyez c'est pour ça que la
question des quotas d'immigration est
une question très importante elle peut
le faire dès lors qu'est l'art de
commissions et oui dès lors qu'elle a un
principe qui celui d'un raid intégré
toutes celles et tous ceux qui veulent
rester sur le territoire d'un pays merci
et jérôme chartier d'avoir fait le tour
de l'actualité politique et
parlementaire de la semaine merci
michael à la semaine prochaine bonne
semaine à tous